as monuments fall across America Trump
gives a barnburner speech in defense of
American history at Mount Rushmore so
the media simply lie about it I
mentioned Peru this is the Ben Shapiro
show today's show is sponsored by
expressvpn stand up or your digital
rights take action at expressvpn comm
slash panel I hope that you had a
wonderful and relaxing July 4th weekend
we did it was really really nice and you
know we'd socially distance didn't we
heard the fireworks that people were
firing off illegally and it was it was a
party whose root is great also worth
noting hospitalizations are rising
around the country from Cova 19 that is
not a shock fuse we've seen an increased
number of cases the death rates continue
to be incredibly low so we are hoping
and praying and crossing our fingers
that we don't see a spike in the death
rates if the rates of infection continue
to rise and the death rates continue to
plateau that's actually really good news
and the media seem not to be hoping for
that media seem to be hoping at any
moment we will be overwhelmed now the
reality is that most hospitals are not
overwhelmed at this point even the
hospitals they are talking about quote
unquote being overwhelmed our hospitals
where the ISEE use are now using some
flex capacity but the fact is this
because they had not been borrowing the
elective surgeries up until the last
week or so there a lot of patients who
are left over from elective surgeries as
of Houston in Houston hospitals as of
last week only about 25% of the beds
were taken up in the IC is by cover 19
patients apparently in some hospitals
that is now up to about 50% of the ICU
beds what that means that they're gonna
cancel the elective surgeries again in
fact they've already done this in
certain parts of Florida in certain
parts of Arizona in certain parts of
California so the hospital
the sort of hospital resources are not
threatened yet at this point plus we now
know how to deal with this thing a lot
better which is really good in certain
steps that have been taken by hospitals
are significantly stronger in terms of
fighting Kovan 19 than they were even a
few months ago so anybody telling you
we're in the same position that we wore
back in March he's lying to you it's
just not true
statistically speaking it is not true
medically speaking we now knows things
we didn't know back then like for
example try to keep people off the
ventilators using ventilators was sort
of a first line of attack at the very
beginning it turns out that was
counterproductive
flipping people on their stomach has
become a very effective practice
apparently so his steroid use there
there are a couple of therapeutic drugs
that are now being used far more widely
the rates of death in hospitals in other
words have gone down fairly radically so
I think we can all hope and pray
together as Americans that even as the
cases increase we continue to see this
plateauing of death because we are the
yesterday on Sunday we had the lowest
level of death in the United States that
we had had since about mid-march since
like March 23rd or something so that is
actually very very good news ok but
that's not a big story of the day across
America the big story of the day across
America continues to be the cultural
revolution we are currently experiencing
now I have never seen I will say this
I've seen the media Gaslight a lot about
President Trump gaslighting suppose you
don't know is a phrase that it is a word
that is used based on a movie from the
1940s called
Gaslight it's about a husband who
marries a wife and then essentially gets
bored with her and decides to get her to
commit suicide by driving her crazy so
he always turns down the light on the on
the stairs and then he will tell her
that the light is not down on the stairs
that's what that's why it's called
Gaslight he will turn down the gas light
on the stairs and then he will tend
she'll say is it dark when he'll say no
it looks fine to me he'll do all sorts
of little things around the house to
make her think that she is crazy and
therefore make her more suicidal right
that is the movie from the nineteen
forties start saying but Bergman it's
very good little suspense thriller that
has become a term that is used in
politics a lot when you see people who
are saying things that are obviously not
true
but with the full sincerity of saying
that they are true so over the weekend
President Trump gave his speech at Mount
Rushmore and we'll get to the speech in
a while because the speech was a
barnburner the speech is really really
good okay I think it is the best speech
that Trump has ever given I think the
speech was right on the money we'll go
through it in just a few minutes but the
media are totally gaslighting this thing
so they're suggesting two separate
things about President Trump speech both
of which are wildly inaccurate the first
line of attack is that Trump is just
delusional and all the stuff that he's
talking about in his speech as we'll see
did not happen it's never happened so
when Trump talks about the destruction
of American history or the canceled
culture all this is a figment of his
imagination he's just sort of imagined
this now if you've been following the
news for the last few months you might
say to yourself wait what
like what what no of course this stuff
is real what we've been watching people
talking openly about tearing down
statues of George Washington we've
watched statues at Thomas Jefferson
two-faced and torn down we've seen in
multiple areas statues of Christopher
Columbus come down in fact over the
weekend
there's a Columbus statue those toppled
by Baltimore protestors over the weekend
in another act of vandalism they just
pulled the statue right down you can see
the people cheering wildly as the statue
topples over collapses on its head and
splits it in half and then you see this
group of world protestors what achieve
what an achievement did they sail across
an ocean and open up a continent to
Western civilization no they pulled it
they pulled a piece of stone off the
pedestal and now they're dancing around
like maniacs and throwing them throwing
the peace in the heart of all these
Wolfe white people or cheering OH made a
difference in the world it's something
we'll tell our non-existing
grandchildren about because we're never
gonna have kids probably it's really
just excellent excellent stuff from
these protesters over the weekend we saw
a monument to the Oregon Trail families
demolished in Portland so people who
cross the continent and made Portland a
city those people that are there now
pulling down the stache poet if I have
to hear again from protesters who I
don't see any of them giving up their
studio apartments to indigenous peoples
you know they do this whole routine
about how the settling of the western
United States was all about colonialism
and invasion and again that's true right
it's true it's true that throughout
human history people have been
colonialist throughout human history
people have been imperialists throughout
human history people have settled vast
wildernesses and let's be frank about
this the United States was largely a
vast wilderness Haley yes there were
indigenous peoples but in terms of the
percentage of population to the amount
of land it was relatively depopulated
okay that does not mean you get to steal
other people's land presumably as a
general moral principle but let's just
be real about this that is the entire
history of humanity but there is this
new fangled morality that says okay well
we have to condemn the existence of the
United States because there were Native
American peoples who are here before
this ignoring of course the fact that
various tribes were deport were stealing
land from one another and attacking one
another and again that is all of human
history that is not unique to Western
civilization it is all of human history
for all time and I will mote again that
all the same people who are suggesting
that America is stolen land don't seem
to be giving up their apartments anytime
soon I haven't seen any of them go over
to the the Native American tribes local
American tribes and say you know what I
own this apartment building when I
inherit it guess what I'm doing I'm
giving it back to you right that none of
that is happening of course all these
protests were true signaling means
begets
without actually having to do any of the
things so they've torn down a monument
to the Oregon Trail families who made it
possible for them to live in places like
Portland and by the way who are
incredibly brave the pioneers were
incredibly brave people when his last
time you got in a covered wagon with no
count'em no police protection and then
decided that you were just going to
wander across a giant piece of land and
take three months in doing so fording
the rivers and shooting the squirrels
just like you did in the game Oregon
Trail but don't worry you are brave
because you torched a monument to the
people who did that sort of stuff you're
the real hero
you're the real hero so here is the
monument to Oregon Trail Families being
demolished over the weekend really well
done those families were the bad guys
they they by the way there's no evidence
that that this particular family that is
honored here was going around killing
Native Americans maybe they just came
out to a deep populated area and just
put down a settlement who the hell knows
but apparently very very bad and people
put on it a sign that said stolen land
this is stolen land okay well I very
much look forward to you going back to
your ancestral homeland of Europe the
white people who apparently put up the
sign that says this is stolen land
meanwhile in the craziest statue
toppling of the weekend apparently a
statue of Frederick Douglass was toppled
we still don't know who did this right
so there are people who are suggesting
that maybe this is the alt-right and
revenge which would of course be
absolutely disgusting Frederick Douglass
is one of the great heroes of American
history of freed slave who called upon
the United States to fulfill its
honorable proclamations in the
Declaration of Independence talks about
Frederick Douglass a lot right before
July 4th on this show apparently the
Frederick Douglass statue in Maplewood
park was removed from its base overnight
and bits of the statute were scattered
about the area apparently it was
eventually found in a ditch about 50
yards distant with one of the fingers
broken so it's unclear who did this sort
of thing who the hell knows bottom line
is the statues are being torn down and
let's be real about this this is now a
sort of mainstream and increasingly
mainstream Democratic position is that
the statue should come down hey Joe
Biden has taken the sort of halfway
position which is let's take down the
Confederate statues which again I think
in some cases is justifiable but let's
leave up these statues of Washington and
Jefferson and Columbus which is the
mainstream American position when I say
it's halfway what I mean is I don't
believe him I don't believe him I don't
believe that Joe Biden is going to fend
off his left I just don't
think it's a thing that he's going to do
I think he is saying that for now
because he knows that the American
people are not with the program in terms
of wiping away all of American history
but I think that increasingly the
Democratic is with that program of
wiping out all of American history as I
talk about my new book how to destroy
America in three easy steps comes out in
about two weeks at this point that is
the goal the goal is to wipe away make
American history recast it as something
dark and malicious and evil to recast
America's Declaration of Independence is
terrible as you'll see this is ongoing
is ongoing the great heroes of our time
like Colin Kaepernick civil rights
heroes like Colin Kaepernick
an extraordinarily rich quarterback who
is perfectly fine with July 4th until he
got benched for Blaine Gabbert at which
point July 4th became terrible they
spent the weekend just ripping on July
4th as we'll get to it this is
increasingly the position of the
mainstream Democratic Party we're gonna
get some more of this in just one second
first let's be frank about this you're
spending a lot of money on your cell
phone you really don't need to be
phone
by switching to pure talk to USA you can
cut cost and free up cash on a monthly
basis starting with your wireless
provider sure talk covers 99% of
Americans the president and CEO of pure
talk is u.s. veteran who cares deeply
about serving Americans by making
wireless affordable so start your saving
today start saving today by dialing
pound two fifty and say key word to Ben
Shapiro or unlimited talk unlimited text
two gigs of data for just 20 bucks a
month plus they'll get 50% off your
first month which means it is now 10
bucks for your first month I mean that's
what you're gonna need one of the
reasons you're paying like 100 bucks a
month is because you have the unlimited
data are you really using the unlimited
data probably not what you need is the
unlimited talk the unlimited text and
two gigs of data
20 bucks a month stop paying too much
too big wireless provider switch to peer
talk today say 50% off your first month
the coverage is just as good as any of
the big wireless networks now pound 250
say key word Ben Shapiro heard talk to
us a simply smarter wireless again now
pound 250 say key word Ben Shapiro sure
talk USA simply smarter Wireless dial
pounds you 50 say key word Ben Shapiro
and again to get 50% off your very first
month okay so tammy duckworth a senator
who is now being considered as a
possible Biden VP pick over the weekend
she's a senator from Illinois she
suggested that she was possibly willing
to listen to talk about tearing down
statues of George Washington so here is
again this is becoming an increasing
that starts off on the radical left
eventually makes its way into the heart
of the Democratic Party and what the
democratic party does they play this
game where the radical left says
something crazy like you fund the police
and the Democratic Party goes that's
crazy man we're never gonna do that and
then you look at your watch and about 73
seconds later they're like you know what
you know what maybe we should defund the
police so five seconds ago Joe Biden is
like nah we probably shouldn't touch
Washington or Lincoln or Jefferson five
seconds ago Barack Obama did a speech at
Mount Rushmore right and now they're
turning around they're like five seconds
ago by way Tammy Duckworth dressed up as
Mount Rushmore for for July 4th I'm not
kidding I'm not kidding okay there's a
tweet from her in 2015
talking about house as a patriotic
American she's gonna dress up as Mount
Rushmore and now she's like maybe we
should continue no I don't want to put
it out of consideration and maybe we
should we should tear down statues of
George Washington or something should
statues for example of George Washington
come down well let me just say that we
should start off by having a national
dialogue his priorities are all wrong
here he should be talking about what
we're gonna do to overcome this pandemic
what are we going to do to push Russia
back and instead he had no time for that
he's got all his time talking about dead
traitors so that made me be true but
George Washington I don't think anybody
would call him a traitor and there are
moves by some to remove statues of him
is that a good idea I think we should
listen to everybody we should listen to
everybody is a mainstream Democratic
position increasingly get rid of the
monuments that's an increasingly popular
position in the Democratic Party
not just the Confederate statues right
Dana Bash actually does a good job there
she clarified she says are you talking
about George Washington's like I think
we should listen to everybody we should
listen to the reason I'm setting up this
predicate guys is because what the media
are about to say is that when Trump
talks about it it didn't ever happen it
never happened it was all a lie it just
was made up it's in Crimea by the way
even there you hear Tammy Duckworth
flying hey Tammy Duckworth is openly
lying right there she says Trump talked
about Confederate statues over the
weekend he did not at no point during
his speech at Mount Rushmore you can
mention anything about Confederate
statues in fact as you'll see all he
discussed was the glory of abolitionism
and the greatness of the Union I mean
it's just bad as a figment of your
imagination it's an open lie it's an
open line when Tammy Duckworth is saying
right there which is that he paid
tribute to dead traitors you
there's a whole list of people as we
will see in Trump speech that he
mentioned by name not one of them is a
traitor not one of them okay so this is
just
that's insane as we say this is kin this
is a mission here the continuing
destruction of America's history that I
talked about at length my book that
discontinuing destruction of American
history is a page Colin Kaepernick has
now been made the social justice
conscience of the NFL this
extraordinarily rich mediocre
quarterback at best
okay this extraordinarily privileged guy
this is a person of tremendous privilege
men earn a million dollars from Nike for
kneeling on an ad he does that pretend
that this guy is not a beneficiary of
the American system Colin Kaepernick
it's insane hey that guy who is posing
in like communist regalia while he was
in the NFL and wearing socks it had
pictures of cops as pigs on them and
then he was kneeling for the anthem and
we were told by the way then we was
kneeling for the anthem he was not in
fact kneeling for the anthem remember
this was the line because every mom is
he was not kneeling for the anthem
remember they said that he was just
kneeling because he was upset about
police brutality and systemic and
systemic racism right it wasn't at the
anthem
it wasn't disrespect to soldiers it
wasn't disrespect to the founding wasn't
disrespect to the flag it was about
respect for the flag of course because
he was just standing up for what's best
about America except for yesterday he
over the weekend he put up a tweet that
said black people have been dehumanized
brutalized criminalized and terrorized
by America for centuries and are
expected to join your commemoration of
Independence while you enslaved our
ancestors we reject your celebration of
white supremacy and look forward to
liberation for all and then he put up a
video of all of these horrifying images
from American history linked inherently
with the with things like police
shootings as the lynchings in 1920 are
the same as a disputed case of a police
shooting during up during a stop during
a police stop
like this is the stuff that colin
kaepernick is putting out well tweeting
that independent state is inherently
terrible and very very bad what did the
light Colin Kaepernick is what a
wonderful learner and the media are
pushing this forward by the way the
media love this stuff they love it
the way that the canceled culture comes
from everybody as we'll discuss but the
the media love this have CNN over the
weekend so Trump speaking at Mount
Rushmore and Trump and and the CNN
reporter it's almost impossible describe
how insane this is from CNN the CNN
reporter starts talking about Mount
Rushmore and discusses Mount Rushmore as
stolen Native American lands and a
statue of at least two slaveholders and
the way that CNN creates its Chiron the
Siena and Chiron says re-examining
independence day they put independence
and scare quotes it's not Independence
Day anymore which by the way is the
official name of the holiday right under
the law under the US code there's an
actual section the discusses the
establishment holidays it is called
officially in the United States
Independence Day on CNN however it is
scare quote Independence Day because not
Independence Day it's bad July 4th is
bad here's a CNN reporter trying to talk
down at Mount Rushmore again I'm said it
I'm pointing out to you you're not crazy
don't be ghastly you're not crazy all
this stuff was happening because now
that Trump said that it was happening
the media's like it never happened
it never happened you imagined it you
met we never turned that gas light down
we never did the gas light's always the
same as it's ever been
there's no threat to America's history
or her culture or her freedoms there's
no threat to any of those things we're
not trying to indoctrinate you in a view
of America no we're not you're just
crazy mm-hmm
here is CNN over the weekend again
declaring Mount Rushmore erased his
sight of white supremacy as Americans
face a reckoning over racism past and
present there is no message of healing
from the White House instead President
Trump is calling a black lives matter
Street mural a symbol of hate and Jake
kicking off the Independence Day weekend
President Trump will be at Mount
Rushmore where he'll be standing in
front of a monument of to slave owners
and on land wrestled away from Native
Americans told that be focusing on the
effort to quote tear down our country's
history
ok tear down our country's history but
that's bad he's gonna quote great scare
quote bat in a skillet and turn our
country's history as you talk about how
its slaveholders I Mount Rushmore
because again people are being
deliberately obtuse here you're being
deliberately obtuse the reason that
Thomas Jefferson and George Washington
are on that monument is not
slave holders the idiocy of suggesting
when you build a memorial to people who
did great things well you're actually
memorializing these all they're worse
things is the stupidest thing in the
entire world we have giant statues of
Martin Luther King all over the United
States nearly every state in the United
States independently independently
created a Martin Luther King holiday
before the federal holiday was passed in
fact is a massive massive controversy in
the United States in the 1980s when a
couple of states wouldn't do it okay
Martin Luther King by available evidence
was horrible to women okay there's
there's very very good evidence that
Martin Luther King treated women
abominably is that why we're but should
we tear down as memorials of course not
because that's not why we remember about
Luther King nobody thinks that when we
memorialize Martin Luther King what were
actually doing is memorializing all the
ways he mistreated women like this is
the insanity of suggesting that when you
put up a statue to a person what you're
doing is you're honoring every single
thing about the person it's just
ridiculous it's ridiculous on its face
but again the entire idea here is that
the heart of the Jefferson experience is
the delivery the declaration is just a
cover for it the heart of George
Washington was the fact that he was a
slaveholder not the fact that he was the
father of the country the heart of
Abraham Lincoln is that Abraham Lincoln
was in favor of Liberia not that he was
focused on emancipating the slaves right
that is the that is the general tenor
toward American history that so many
people in the media in our in our
academic culture are seeking to take and
then you combine that with the canceled
culture and you come up with something
truly ugly so as you'll see again I'm
just foreshadowing because you need to
know where I'm going here okay the fact
is that the canceled culture exists it
is extraordinarily ugly it's
particularly ugly for people on the left
actually because if I'm if you're on the
right
like I know conservatives are not
interested in canceling other
conservatives and they're not gonna go
along with this if you're on the Left
you probably will be cancelled because
your own crowd is going to flee from you
screaming and running for the hills with
their hair on fire the minute that you
are called out as anything approaching
the racist that's the way that this
works but the left is gonna claim that
because Trump mentioned canceled culture
at Mount Rushmore it doesn't exist
again figment of your imagination gas
lighting wouldn't get to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that sleep is very difficult to
come by these days my baby is waking us
up like eight times a night it is a good
thing she is cute because she is a
trouble muffin she's very much a child
who keeps us awake and then we got a
six-year-olds wanders into our room and
wants to wake up well what do I mean
what does this matter the reason it
matters
cuz in those spare moments when I can
get to sleep I need to fall asleep
immediately and I need to be comfortable
and helix sleep it makes all of that
happen helix sleep has a quiz it takes
just 2 minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences - the perfect mattress for
you whether you're a side sleeper or a
hot sleeper I feel like a pleasure from
bed with helix there's no more confusion
and no more compromising Hewett sleep is
rated the number one mattress by GQ and
Wired magazine CNN called it the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on just go to helix sleep comm / Ben
take their 2 minutes sleep quiz it will
match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep of your
life they have a 10 year warranty you
get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
hulex is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders for our listeners
again up to $200 off at helix sleep comm
/ Ben that is helix sleep comm / my my
wife and I have a helix sleep mattress
it is why we are capable of getting
through the day despite the fact that
our children are determined and they've
in fact created molotov-ribbentrop pact
of keeping us awake and so we need this
mattress so do you
hulex sleep they're offering up to the
$200 off all mattress orders helix sleep
calm / man helix sleep calm / man go
check them out right now okay so the
cancel culture is real - okay so you
combine the perception of American
history that all American history is
evil and racist with the belief that if
you do anything within the systems of
the United States
you can fairly be labeled a racist right
this is the how to be an anti-racist
Abram X can be nonsense that the left
has been pushing for the past several
years at the idea being that if you are
complicit in any system in America
you're a racist any system in America
even the most innocuous gestures get you
canceled because after all the most
innocuous gestures are just generating
support for this horrible evil system
that ends with inequality at the
endpoints and so that means it doesn't
matter how left you are it doesn't
matter how good you have been on
progressive issues you will be cancelled
over the weekend both lin-manuel Miranda
and Hamilton creator Jeffrey Sela were
forced to apologize okay they created
Hamilton which again is a pretty
astonishingly diverse musical right I'm
not a Hamilton fan I've done a whole bit
on Hamilton on the show before I got
problems with Hamilton mostly from an
artistic perspective but even from a
general perspective that you can only
identify with people of your own race
playing people we're not of that race
I've always found bizarre like
I grew up listening to 1776 and watching
1776 not a Jew among the bunch but I
never had a problem identifying with the
characters just as you know if you watch
a great movie with somebody who is not
of your race
you were seemly identified with people
who are not of your race and Italy's in
any case putting putting all of that
aside it's a it's a very patriotic
musical I mean the musical is about the
greatness of America and about the
establishment of America yeah well
lin-manuel miranda and hamilton creator
Jeffrey seller according to Emily Zhen
Nadia Daly where were forced to
apologize over the weekend for failing
to adequately address the black lives
matter movement and for quote taking
part in the moral failure of not
speaking up amid the ongoing protests
taking place across the nation over the
death of George Floyd in Minneapolis
according to The Hollywood Reporter
Miranda said in a video posted over the
weekend to his Twitter account
we spoke out on the day of the pulse
shooting we spoke out when vice
president pence came to our show ten
days after the election that we have not
yet firmly spoken the in arguable truth
that black lives matter and to now
systemic racism and white supremacy from
our official Hamilton channels is a
moral failure on our part is what
Miranda said as the writer of that show
I take responsibility and apologize for
my part in this moral failure yet he was
sorry for quote not pushing harder and
faster for us to speak these
self-evident truths under the Hamilton
banner which has come to mean so much to
many of you
Hamilton doesn't exist without the black
and brown artists who created and
revolutionized and changed the world
through the culture music and language
of hip-hop literally the idea of the
show doesn't exist without brilliant
black and brown artists in our cast from
production team will breathe life into
this story every time it's performed and
then seller also apologized he said I'm
not a politician I'm not an activist I'm
not an expert I'm a theatre producer
what I realized today is most
importantly I'm an American citizen and
silence equals complicity and I
apologize for my silence thus far
silence equals complicity hey so it
doesn't matter how woke you are it
doesn't matter how progressive you are
it doesn't matter you created one the
most successful pieces of art in a
modern American history
entirely with people of color it does
not matter none of that matters you will
be called out if you didn't dedicate the
entire Hamilton webpage to George Floyd
or something was anyone under the grave
misimpression that lin-manuel Miranda or
than any of the people who were
originally involved in this thing were
deeply racist and we're standing with
Derek Shelvin in that case like who are
these people the canceled culture is
real and it comes after everybody who's
willing to cave to it and it leads to
some of the most bizarre outcomes
imaginable another example
for years this is according to the New
York Times people have been calling for
John T edge to step down as head of the
influential southern foodways Alliance
they say he is kingmaker they say he's a
white man however charming who has too
much power over who tells the story of
food in a region where so much of the
cuisine was created by enslaved people
for years mr. edge has been listening
and remained in his position at the top
he said recently I'll listen hard and
with as much intensity as I can out of a
moment of Cerne and righteous critique
becomes a better organization the work
we've done over the last twenty years
has worked at his crude remission work
the despite flaws and I may see and
others may see is intended to make
progress and make positive change in a
region I've always loved and sometimes
hate but listening might not be enough
anymore before there were biscuits all
over Brooklyn and barbecue pitmasters
made the list of America's best chefs 50
cooks and writers shared a meal in
Birmingham Alabama in 1999 1999 and
created the southern foodways Alliance
the idea was subversive with food as a
lens the organization aimed to preserve
the intricacies of the southern table in
a way that would both erase the nation's
corn pone concepts about the region's
food and help heal a tortured racial
racist history now people are calling
for edge who's the founder of the
organizations who leave why is he not
progressive because he's white because
he's white that's literally the entire
thing that's the entire thing a chorus
of voices is rising
mr. edge say his critics is a statue
that needs to come down author Louis
Eric le 57 a founder of the organization
says I view misses your friend in a
close ally the principles don't mean
anything until they cost you something
and John's he is a man of great
principle who may end up paying a great
price in this context according to
Marcie Cohen Ferris 63 a former board
president and professor emeritus in
American Studies at UNC University of
North Carolina what we have is a
middle-aged man who like so many
progressive southerners has wrestled
with the demons of his white southern
past and used that to help build a
better south the reconciliation stance
is no longer going to work in this
nation it's about economics and justice
this is it this is the moment so they're
gonna they're gonna force this guy he's
a progressive they're going to force him
out so that there can be a black person
who takes his place it's literally the
entire thing that's literally the entire
thing there's a guy who wants his job
okay and his name is tunde way a
Nigerian born chef and
writer and he wrote a piece talking
about how he wanted edge to step aside
and give his position of power to an
african-american woman so I guess not he
doesn't want the job done said he was a
black woman to take the job and then
days later Ronny Lundy 78 founder in the
organization wrote a pointed Facebook
post and delivered a letter calling for
him to step aside her litany of issues
centered on sexism she said that it was
a bro culture she said it was fifteen
symposiums before women were selected as
a focal point in 2013 so it doesn't
matter how progressive you are doesn't
matter what you believe you'll be forced
out if you are a participant in a system
that has not been turned over to the
right people the people who are higher
on the local pyramid how bad is this the
head of the College Democrats was forced
to resign
okay the florid the head of the College
Democrats was a person of color
apparently her name is Michaela Guido
hey well she was I believe of Hispanic
descent and she was forced to resign why
well in an open letter published Tuesday
forty-one of the College Democrats 47
federations representing 39 states DC
and Puerto Rico expressed solidarity
with a black board member Matthew
nailing who's going to now take the
place of the president why well what
they demanded the the resignation of the
president commitments from every board
member they would not run for reelection
or accept any future leadership position
within the College Democrats and
amendments to the organization's
governing and documents just before
Guido stepped down on Wednesday
afternoon she appointed knelling as vice
president so the person who's calling
her to leave she appointed him as VP and
he accepted meaning he takes over the
organization members said that what did
she do wrong
utterly unclear their vote began when
mr. nailing 21 announced his resignation
from the board on Saturday the open
letter was first published with the
signatures of 17 Federation's within
hours that number had more than doubled
mr. nailing a student at Denison
University in Ohio who was elected to
the board last year and began his term
in September said other members had
routinely ignored his suggestions to
mean him and cast him as lazy and
incompetent okay what so like seriously
so he says that these are racist strokes
used against black people for
generations to prevent them from
advancing in the workplace when he
suggested the College Democrats host a
town hall on diversity he recalled in an
inner
on Tuesday one board member laughed out
loud others did not take the idea
seriously until a white member backed
him up a board member once Montes
clothing is cheap and suggested he take
it back to the thrift store on another
occasion a state Federation leader
complained he focused too much on black
issues Nelly said the Guido had been
complicit Rito's a law student
University of Florida she said she was
even aware of the allegations until he
told her he was resigning and she'd
heard the offending board members to
resign as soon as soon as she found out
but it wasn't enough then she resigned
then she resigned she said I may not be
the person membership feels represents
them currently I may need to make space
for someone who does they cancel the
cancelling will continue until morale
improves by the way one of the Boeing
cheats that Boeing communications chief
has now been forced out of his job why
because 33 years ago he wrote a piece
arguing women shouldn't be in combat hey
that's like a hot topic right now okay
the question of how far women should
serve in combat considering that the
average woman is less physically strong
than the average male I mean this is
like an open issue okay it's an open
issue in Israel like which positions and
Israel has one of the most integrated by
sex forces on planet earth right the IDF
is very integrated between men and women
there are specific areas where women
generally do not serve in the IDF as far
as my understanding this is a very hot
issue now here what this thirty three
years ago thirty three years ago and
they ousted him from Boeing he said my
argument was embarrassingly wrong and
offensive the article is not a
reflection of Who I am
nonetheless I decided in the interest of
the company I will step down
he said that issue is not whether women
can fire em sixties dogfight MiG's or
drive tanks introducing women into
combat would destroy the exclusively
male intangibles of war fighting and the
feminine feminine images of what men
fight for peace home and family okay
like not the best but also like at the
very the by the way the one of the one
of those aspects is not necessarily the
best but the latter part that sends but
the stuff about like how you have male
camaraderie and that women don't
necessarily fit directly into male
camaraderie is a hundred percent true
and if your verse the sexes it would
obviously be true in Reverse as well and
if you introduce a bunch of men into an
all women's group it changes the math a
little bit right pretending there's no
difference between the sexes is very
very silly but even if you think that
guy was wrong it was 33 years ago 33
years ago with a perfectly legitimate
general argument about women in combat
positions okay like what in the world
what in the actual f the best example of
this the best example of the cancelling
I love this this is fantastic so New
York's education New York City's
Education Council is apparently just a
complete bleep show so there was a a
hearing and everybody is socially
distancing right now so they did this
all online and during the meeting one
board member of the New York City
Education Council had a friend's kid
over the friends nephew or something and
the kid is a is a kid of color I'm not
sure what the kid is non-white okay the
kid is either black or Hispanic a boy
and the board member takes the kid and
puts the kid on his lap well in the
middle of the meeting any board member
named Robin bro she then starts create a
white person starts screaming at this
guy he's forwarding racism by having a
child of color on his lap in a New York
City Education Council meeting and this
is why no one should ever read Robyn
D'Angelo ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever so what so joe biden he
says and he's gonna transform the nation
right this is his pledge he tweeted out
that he is going to transform the nation
he said we're going to beat Donald Trump
and when we do we won't just rebuild
this nation will transform it and so
there many of us who look at what's
going on in the country would say well I
wonder what you mean by transforming the
country slow old Joe what do you mean do
you mean that you're in favor of
listening to the folks who want to tear
down Washington statues or do you mean
you're in favor of a canceled culture
that goes after people for the great sin
of being white in progressive
organizations like what exactly are we
talking about here do you mean anyone
destroy like so many on your radical
left flank to America's history her
culture her notion of philosophy like
where are you gonna are you want to be
the
work against the radical left here
because understand for a lot of people
whatever Trump's flaws
whatever Trump's problems and believe me
I have detailed them extensively on this
program whatever the problems you have
with Donald Trump the vast majority of
people who support Trump support Trump
not because they believe that Trump is
some sort of incredibly pure human being
they believe that he is a bulwark
against what's coming it is that simple
and the more radical the left is the
more they see Trump is just the guy
standing in the breach
okay so against that backdrop Trump goes
to Mount Rushmore and he gives what I
think his most important speech of his
presidency I thought it was nearly
letter perfect I really did I thought
his great speech now I wish that he had
given a little bit more of a nuanced
version of American history but that's
really my only critique the generalized
the generalized theme of the speech is
exactly right I don't know who wrote
this one but this is probably the best
week she's ever given it wasn't
delivered the best that he's ever
delivered a speech because whenever he
get tell it teleprompter Trump he's not
as exciting and fun as the eye goes to
rallies and sort of rifts about going
downstairs and stuff but it was it was a
really well-written speech and if people
were honest in the slightest about this
they would recognize that what he's
saying ought to be utterly
uncontroversial but it is not and so
again we get the two media narratives
they're gonna come out of the speech
we're gonna play a lot of the speech now
we're gonna get the to media nerves that
come out of the speech and keep them in
the back your mind keep them in your
mind so you know and when you're
listening to the speech you can spot the
lies just by listening to the speech one
is everything he's criticizing isn't
happening
right it's although I it's all he's The
Gaslight is not turned down it's all I
it's figment of his imagination that's
line number one and then line number two
is that the President of the United
States was doing all of this in order to
honor Confederates this whole speech was
truly about saving Confederate memorials
which is more solid ground for Democrats
right they claim that they want to
remove Washington statues most Americans
are like not not up for it they say they
want to remove a statue of Stonewall
Jackson people
okay maybe okay but Trump at no point
did any of that so the media are just
lying about this they called the speech
dark they called it depressing it is
nothing of the sort
nothing nothing I've rarely seen a case
of the media openly lying like openly
usually they try to hide it this is just
open line they assume like everybody
else assumes you're not gonna listen to
Trump speech they seem you're not gonna
sit through a half hour 35 minute speech
from the President of the United States
and you'll just read the headline from
the
can post or the New York Times that's
the assumption and so they run headlines
like these okay this was the LA Times
headline at Mount Rushmore Trump uses
fourth of July celebration to stoke a
culture war right he started he started
the culture war not the people tearing
down statues and getting white
progressives fired from their positions
and cleansing newsrooms of the evil
editors who run Tom cotton op eds and
using universities to Batna tutu to hurl
brickbats and particular professor x' to
rewrite american history to suggest that
the Declaration of Independence is it
documents evil and that July 4th is not
Independence Day but his repression day
he didn't it Trump started the culture
war the only times at Mount Rushmore
Trump uses fourth of July celebration to
stoke a culture war New York Times Trump
uses Mount Rushmore speech to deliver it
to vice hip culture war message he
started it right
Associated Press these are again
remember these are objective news
reports Associated Press Trump pushes
racial division flouts virus rules at
Rushmore as you'll see there's not a
word of racial division in the speech
not one not one iota at all zero zip
zilch Washington Post and Mount Rushmore
Trump exploits social divisions warns of
left-wing Cultural Revolution in darks
speech ahead of Independence Day Robert
Costa at the Washington Post tweeted out
president Trump's unyielding push to
preserve Confederate symbols which he
didn't mention not a one time in this
entire speech and the legacy of white
domination the legacy of white
domination was crystallized by his harsh
denunciation of the racial justice
movement Friday night at Mount Rushmore
okay if you had just read these honestly
if you just read these headlines what
you would come away with is this is a
fascist Beach in fact there are a bunch
of people who hate Trump of course who
said exactly that right Jennifer Rubin
haha the so-called conservative
columnist she finally removed it from
her Washington Post profile she says it
was a darkly aggressive and fascistic
speech positing that his enemies want to
destroy America and eradicate his
history and eradicate its history well
hold up they literally want to destroy
America and eradicated history that's
not the only reason to oppose Trump many
of trumps opponents don't learn to do
that but there are some opponents of
Trump many who do in fact want to
eradicate America's history and destroy
the country hey max boots
another one of these former never Trump
errs and again I say that advisor
because I didn't vote for Trump in 2016
but there's a bunch of people who were
driven completely off the off the
deep-end max boot wrote a piece today
Donald Trump is running an openly racist
campaign he said the speech was openly
racist openly racist he says in his
Friday night speech in Mount Rushmore
Trump unveiled a new set of enemies that
he prefers to battle instead until
November his supporters ignored the
actual dangers they face as they packed
in mainly without masks to listen to
trump in bay again it's largely
imaginary foes right there's the
gaslighting it's imaginary none of this
exists no this exists it's all it's all
imaginary guys it's all in your head
what in the heck is he talking about
says max boot only someone who binge
watches fox news in scare quotes as
Trump does can imagine that violent
hordes are marauding through US cities
most of the demonstration occurred in
weeks ago and they were overwhelmingly
peaceful okay now okay now you're just
crazy now what you're saying like I'm
sorry I'm not gonna be gasps let this
way I was locked in my house at 6:00
p.m. every night for a week because
marauding horns were burning Melrose my
Melrose Avenue don't give me it was
mostly peaceful crowds were shutting
down the entire city of Los Angeles in
fact entire County of Los Angeles at 6
p.m. every night and Beverly Hills at 1
p.m. okay that's just absolute sheer
nonsense this is or that millions of
political dissidents are being fired for
disagreeing with a new fire left fascism
no one said Millions funny lots hey
Latin by the way you don't have to fire
that many people for people to get to
get the threads I can't tell you how
many I probably received at this point
hundreds of emails from people saying I
want to speak out against something
happening in my company I'm dead afraid
to do it I mean we get calls like this
on our radio show every single day
multiple a day people saying my company
just did something crazy I'm afraid to
speak out about it because if I do speak
out about him and get fired but it's all
a figment of your imagination
all the thick mints those are the two
lines he's a fascist a deep evil racist
fascist and it's all figment of your
imagination never happened there we're
gonna get to Trump's speech which was
great it's a good speech it is a very
good speech and he actually has to
listen to the speech for all you morons
who just read the headlines and don't
actually listen to the speech listen to
the speech we'll get to it in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that hiring these days can be quite
difficult and there are a lot of
different applicants how do you choose
the right one and if you are an employee
who is looking for an employer and one
of the people who was unfortunately
thrown out of work because of kovaydin
now you're looking for a new job and
maybe you're looking to upgrade and get
a better job
the zip recruiter is for you a housing
wire could relate they needed to hire an
ambitious reporter to cover news stories
on the US mortgage and housing markets
so they turn to zip recruit
zip recruiters smart matching technology
finds people with the right experience
for your job in fact four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter at
equality candidate within a very first
day and that's how housing wire found
Alexandra Roja
Alexandra never imagined she could get a
reporter job in the midst of Cobie 19
but she could she created a profile on
zip recruiter and she began she became
housing wires reporter just within like
hours housing wire receipts for
application for hours after they posted
the job a few weeks later Alexandra
started her dream job zipper career
helped Alexandra find her dream job and
they can do the exact same thing for you
there's a reason we had daily wire you
zip recruiter not only so we can get the
best employees so it can also threaten
are currently unpalatable ones see how
zip recruiter can help you hire try it
now for free at zip recruiter Tom slash
daily wire that is zip recruiter comm
slash daily wear go check them out right
now supercruise comm slash daily wire
okay we'll get to president Trump speech
in a moment because again when you
juxtapose the lies being told about the
speech with the actual speech it's
absolutely astonishing that's that
moment first if you're not already a
daily where I remember you should
consider getting a reader's pass to
daily wear calm it is a great value it's
three bucks a month when you sign up to
get that first month for 99 cents
hundred dolla you also get access to our
mobile app articles had free access to
exclusive editorials like mine from last
week so talat Aryan mob style unity
isn't unity at all if you haven't
checked out the readers pass already go
to daily where comment sign up for just
one dollar you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so now here's President Trump
speech the president Trump goes to Mount
Rushmore there a couple of things about
the speech that you know we should
mention up front I have suggested for a
while the president Trump is doing
something that is politically unwise
when he has these mass rallies where a
lot of people are not wearing masks it
just gives the media an excuse to blame
he's the the Cova 19 spread on him after
spending weeks pretending that if you
were protesting for the right reasons
then you were immune to kovat there's
the story over the weekend the bubonic
plague is broke out out in China which
is very scary until you realize that as
long as we are protesting systemic
American racism we're all fine it
doesn't matter if you go out in the
streets and people have have the buboes
and they've gotten like the big old
they've got the they've got they've got
all of the all of the various
accoutrement of bubonic plague
everything is totally fine so long as
you are protesting the right cause as
long as you're kneeling on the American
flag everything is totally cool so that
that comfort me comforted me a little
bit but if you go to a Trump rally
then you might get bubonic plague okay
that's the media's narrative it's not
wise to play into that but the speech
itself is very good and it points out a
key problem in American society which is
yes there are a group of people in
America right now who wish to see the
Union disintegrated they're a group of
people I call them disintegration is in
my new book how to destroy America in
three easy steps who wants to see
America's history or philosophy or
culture destroyed they want to see it
wiped away they do this is not a figment
of your imagination and you're not crazy
for believing it
all you have to do is talk to a college
student who has been studying Howard
Zinn with their idiot professor all you
have to do is watch CNN or they put
Independence Day in scare quotes all you
have to do is listen to senator Tammy
Duckworth they sitting United States
Senator shift her position on Mount
Rushmore from I'm gonna celebrate Mount
Rushmore five years ago - maybe you
should think about whether we need to
pull down statues of George Washington
Nancy Pelosi by the way and said we
ought to have those conversations as
well yes there is a move of what a very
strong move to rewrite America's history
to rewrite the constitutional bargain
and to tear apart whatever semblance of
unity we could possibly hold so against
that backdrop that's what Trump is
speaking against he did not start his
fight this fight was already going on
before he answered office in fact Trump
was the reaction to that Trump was the
reaction to the attempted rewriting of
American history as evil and terrible
and no-good and very bad the 16:19
project which came about during Trump's
presidency and was a reaction in
to trump it's not as though the
predicate for that hasn't been laid over
the past decades
it's just warmed over Howard Zinn and
it's very clear with the 16:19 project
and all of its inglorious terrible
historical retellings what it is hey
this has been an ongoing culture war for
a very long time
Trump arrives and it kicks into high
gear so Trump speaks about it he starts
off by saying something absolutely what
should be absolutely uncontroversial and
would be from any other president right
which is America is pretty damned great
and guess what
the men on the mountain were great men
that doesn't mean that they were sinless
men but they were great men and pointing
out they were great men does not mean
you have to overlook their sins here was
President Trump talking about this
yesterday there could be no better place
to celebrate America's independence than
beneath this magnificent incredible
majestic mountain monument to the
greatest Americans who have ever lived
today we pay tribute to the exceptional
lives at extraordinary legacies of
George Washington Thomas Jefferson
Abraham Lincoln and Teddy Roosevelt I am
here is your President to proclaim
before the country and before the world
this monument will never be desecrated
[Applause]
their legacy will never ever be
destroyed their achievements will never
be forgotten and Mount Rushmore will
stand forever as an eternal tribute to
our forefathers and to our freedom now
what's hilarious to me about media
reactions this is that Trump is talking
about people who literally are calling
for the destruction Mount Rushmore all
right they've actually talked about this
they said the Mount Rushmore is bad
there have been headlines from The
Washington Post and The New York Times
in the last week saying Sons stolen
Native American territory which again
the New York Times is located in last I
checked Manhattan which was which was
bought with for a few beads
okay so New York Times is free to hand
over its its building anytime it wants
to native tribes I do not think they're
going to do that any time the inner
future it's very expensive territory but
the media of said who wants to tear down
Road Mount Rushmore nobody wants to turn
out now Rushmore how could
would even imply that people want to
tear down Mount Rushmore the same people
who are upset with the implication that
Trump is making that people want to tear
down Mount Rushmore cannot understand
why anybody would be upset with the
sloganeering about black lives matter
because many of us are upset with the
implication they're a bunch of people in
America who think black lives don't
matter right that's the objection that
people have the saying black lives
matter not they don't think black lives
matter but that they are annoyed by the
implication there are a bunch of
Americans who think black lives don't
matter
so the media read deeply into every
implication that Trump says and then
ignore the fact that his implications
happen to be true well at the same time
ripping on conservatives who suggest the
implications of certain phrases are
unsupported by evidence okay Trump
continues along these lines any talks up
July 4th again all of this stuff is
wildly uncontroversial now okay I'm like
you let's see if you can spot it can you
spot the darkness here the darkness and
the malevolence and the calls for racial
division anywhere in here and play a lot
of clips of President Trump now see if
you can spot it anywhere because I gotta
be honest with you I'm missing it
because I have eyes and I have ears and
these things function so if I'm not I
feel like I feel like I would get it if
it were there I feel like a would there
was president from talking up July 4th
which here's the here's the reality
people think that he's racist cuz he's
talking about July 4th they actually
agree with Colin Kaepernick they think
that Independence Day is bad and evil
which means that Trump is correct here's
President Trump we gather tonight to
herald the most important day in the
history of nations July 4th 1776 at
those words every American heart
she'd swell with pride every American
family should cheer with delight and
every American patriot should be filled
with joy because each of you lives in
the most magnificent country in the
history of the world and it will soon be
greater than ever before why is this
controversial President Obama's who say
this kind of stuff all the time it was
not the end of the world Trump says it
and apparently the end of the world
because it can read the seething racism
pouring out of his orange head he's a
bad orange man so everything he says he
can say the exact same words as Barack
Obama in the exact same way and it's
like well but Obama meant because he was
funneling more lack of history
Donald Trump Donald Trump he Ziva even
man there either
there's president from talking up the
founding fathers in saying a true thing
our founders launched not only a
revolution in government but a
revolution in the pursuit of justice
equality liberty and prosperity no
nation has done more to advance the
human condition than the United States
of America and no people have done more
to promote human progress than the
citizens of our great nations okay so
the speech is beautifully written it's
not like incredibly well delivered here
but it doesn't matter the per the
president's message is spot-on from the
facts and no Democrat would give the
speech is incredibly telling it's
incredibly telling there is nothing
controversial in this speech there is
nothing that should be controversial in
speech here's President Trump suggesting
that the 56 Patriots who gathered in
Philadelphia we're good we're doing a
good thing which again if you're living
in America and experience the glories of
its benefits you should recognize okay
and we all are
okay the greatest privilege on planet
earth right now is being an American
that is a privilege okay that is a
privilege now white privilege not wealth
privilege living in the United States is
a privilege if you don't believe me try
living try living in China and see how
it goes for you truly they're true
repressive places on earth America is
not one of them here's the president it
was all made possible by the courage of
56 Patriots who gathered in Philadelphia
two hundred and forty-four years ago and
signed the Declaration of Independence
they enshrined a divine truth that
changed the world forever when they said
all men are created equal these immortal
words set in motion the unstoppable
march of freedom
our founders boldly declared that we are
all endowed with the same divine rights
given us by our Creator in heaven and
that which God has given us we will
allow no one ever to take away ever
okay so again nothing controversial here
are you hearing the darkness
i hearing the despair hearing the racial
division i'm not okay so here's where
President Trump starts going after the
people who are actually attempting to
tear down American history the people I
call disintegration is in the book right
here's where he goes after men his
characterization of them is accurate
he's not making it up it's not out of
his head it's not it's not him
creating figment of his imagination or
fake enemies his next boot suggests how
do I know that
I just spent I said I spent half an hour
describing to just the stuff that
happened over the weekend that proved
that what he is saying is not fake hey
here's the president talking about
people who wish to destroy our common
history 1776 represented the culmination
of thousands of years of Western
civilization and the triumph of not only
spirit but of wisdom philosophy and
reason and yet as we meet here tonight
there is a growing danger that threatens
every blessing our ancestors fought so
hard for struggled they bled to secure
our nation is witnessing a merciless
campaign to wipe out our history defame
our heroes erase our values and
indoctrinate our children angry mobs are
trying to tear down statues of our
founders to face our most sacred
memorials and unleash a wave of violent
crime in our cities many of these people
have no idea why they're doing this but
some know exactly what they are doing
they think the American people are weak
and soft and submissive
but no the American people are strong
and proud and they will not allow our
country and all of its values history
and culture to be taken from them okay
so which part of this false there are
angry mobs trying to turn on statue to
the founders
they're literally doing it like right
now also they are trying to erase our
values and defame our heroes and do all
these things and indoctrinate our kids
and we talk about that like where's that
where's the why show me the lie hey then
the president goes on and he describes
canceled culture which again is
absolutely real here's a hunt and if you
don't believe me that it's real ask the
former editor of bone Appetit that's the
guy who from the southern food
Association is currently being cancelled
that's the former editor of the
Philadelphia Enquirer the former op-ed
editor over at the New York Times why
you ask Nicholas Christakis over at Yale
because he's not at yell anymore or
Brett Weinstein over at Evergreen State
College he's not ever at Evergreen State
College anymore that's Brennan I saw
Brett mozilla firefox' yes these things
are real cancel culture is quite real it
is very very real and it comes for us
all sooner or later
my suggestion has been we just all
cancelled let's just declare a universal
canceling and then if everybody has
cancelled nobody's canceled but the
president goes after a canceled culture
which is ugly and terrible and again
show me the lie you can't it's real one
of their political weapons is canceled
culture driving people from their jobs
shaming dissenters and demanding total
submission from anyone who disagrees
this is the very definition of
totalitarianism and it is completely
alien to our culture and to our values
and it has absolutely no place in the
United States of America so naturally
the media wish to ignore what Trump is
saying here so instead what they decide
that they're going to do is just point
out that he can't pronounce
totalitarianism in that in that
particular clip right there that's the
key that's the key they're gonna say
cancel culture doesn't exist literally
there are people online whose entire job
is to try and cancel other people and
literally their entire job is all they
do all day long is they try and find a
way to cancel members of the media they
don't like or outlets they don't like
and then they tweet out things like
canceled cultures are real I am not
kidding it's a real thing that happens
okay so again show me the live spot
Alliance about the device
spot the divisive race to the divisive
racial language it where's the division
where where is it I'm missing it he to
click or ting media he declared the
culture war not only did he declare the
culture war the speech was about
defending Confederate monuments I'm not
kidding this is what they said and they
said that this was a dark divisive and
horrible speech here is the president
suggesting correctly the canceled
culture has now infused most of our
major institutions in our schools our
newsrooms even our corporate boardrooms
there is a new far-left fascism that
demands absolute allegiance if you do
not speak its language performance
rituals recite its mantras and follow
its Commandments then you will be
censored banished blacklisted persecuted
and punished it's not going to happen to
us
make no mistake this left-wing Cultural
Revolution is designed to overthrow the
American Revolution in so doing they
would destroy the very civilization that
rescued billions from poverty disease
violence and hunger and that lifted
humanity to new heights of achievement
discovery and progress to make this
possible they are determined to tear
down every statue symbol and memory of
our national heritage correct correct
and this is all right it's obviously
true and but again the gaslighting
continues apace and then he talks about
how they've rewritten American history
which of course is correct and he talked
about how any movement that seeks to
dismantled these treasured American
legacies can't really love America with
him I wanted to his transform America
which by the way is the language that
Joe Biden and then purposefully used
over the weekend I Trump said these
people weren't transform America and
that's what Joe Biden says he wants to
do is transform America now here's the
most amazing thing people called the
speech racist they said it was racist
okay I'm gonna play a clip now that is
not only not racist it is openly
anti-racism right um so here's President
Trump saying speaking universal
principles from our Declaration of
Independence and again you tell me what
where's the white supremacist messenger
where is that I've been told this is a
white supremacist speech see if you can
spot the white supremacist message
embedded in this particular clip we will
stay the truth in full without apology
we declare that the United States of
America is the most just an exceptional
nation ever to exist on earth we are
proud of the fact that our country was
founded on judeo-christian principles
and we understand that these values have
dramatically advanced the cause of peace
and justice throughout the world we know
that the American family is the bedrock
of American life we believe in equal
opportunity equal justice and equal
treatment for citizens of every race
background religion and create every
child of every color born and unborn is
made in the holy image of God we want
free and open debate not speech coats
and cancel culture we embrace tolerance
not prejudice
we support the courageous men and women
of law enforcement
we will never abolish our police or our
great Second Amendment which gives us
the right to keep
we believe that our children should be
taught to love their country honor their
history and respect our great American
flag we stand tall we stand proud and we
only kneel to Almighty God does that
sound dark and terrible to you any of
that if does then I think that you're
getting America wrong because that seems
like pablum I mean that is perfect that
is that is honestly just bumper sticker
stuff that every American should believe
right that's like the easiest thing in
the world that's the stuff you learn
about America when you're in third grade
right we want free and open bait we like
tolerance not prejudice we support law
enforcement we don't run abolish the
police we think people should love the
country like this is this is very easy
stuff this is American as apple pie
motherhood is good kind of stuff where
is the racism in we believe in equal
opportunity equal justice and equal
treatment for citizens of every race
background religion and Creed every
child of every color born and unborn is
made in the holy image of God is that
racist to you he's always told the
speech was a racist fascist explain it
to me really I'm missing it by the way
he then talked up Martin Luther King I
think three separate times in the speech
three separate times in the speech and
then he talked he gave a list of people
he considered American heroes and in
this list of people he considered
American heroes he names and will count
them one Fred okay Frederick Douglass
the Tuskegee Airmen Harriet Tubman Jesse
Owens Louis Armstrong Muhammad Ali
because he named at least six at least
six black Americans also I believe here
and I think a name checked out with its
geralt is that seven black Americans
plus Martin Luther King who he named
checked I think three times in the
speech so in this deeply racist speech
he named checks eight black people okay
that clearly this man is a vicious
vicious racist clearly is a vicious
vicious racist hey again this is all
perfectly obvious stuff hey then the
notion that there's a racist fascistic
speech is insane it's insane I'm sorry
and it's and it's obviously a lie he
says at one point is that clip 20 he
says we must a man our children are
taught once again to see America as did
Martin Luther King here is a here is
clip 13 we must demand that our children
are taught once again
to see America as did Reverend Martin
Luther King when he said that the
founders had signed a promissory note to
every future generation dr. King saw
that the mission of Justice required us
to fully embrace our founding ideals
those ideals are so important to us the
founding ideals he called on his fellow
citizens not to rip down their heritage
but to live up to their heritage above
all our children from every community
must be taught that to be American is to
inherit the spirit of the most
adventurous and confident people ever to
walk the face of the earth
sounds really dark and depressing right
dark depressing terrible fascistic
racist standing up for Confederate
monuments which you never mentioned not
once in the entire speech and when she
discussed abolitionism an Abraham
Lincoln multiple times the media's lies
are truly astonishing and you know the
media's lies are really about really in
the end they're about misdirection
they're on this direction from true
problems occurring in the country
because it is more comfortable to talk
about tearing down the system than it is
to talk about real problems that are
afflicting real people in the United
States over the weekend a seven-year-old
girl was shot to death in Chicago
this isn't misdirection by me this is a
real issue is a dead person is a dead
child and apparently it doesn't deserve
to be at the top of the news well it
deserves to be at the top of the news is
big charges of systemic racism by police
and defund the police and the police are
the bad guys according to the Chicago
sun-times a seven-year-old girl died
Saturday after being shot at a family
fourth of July party in Austin the third
weekend in a row in Chicago that scene a
child under 10 among the city's shooting
victims clearly this is all about the
white supremacist system right and
that's what we should be focusing on the
girl was playing on a sidewalk around 7
p.m. in the 100 block of North Latrobe
Avenue when three men got out of a white
car and shot more than 20 times in the
direction of the people holding the
party a group the police said included
many children up while the police said
it must have in the cops probably was
the cops the kids were riding by on
bicycles enjoying the 4th of July as
they should have been said Fred Waller
the Chicago Police Department's chief of
operations the girl identified by her
family as Natalia Wallace was shot in
the forehead and pronounced dead at
Stroger Hospital an autopsy ruled her
death a homicide
and there's a picture of her obviously a
beautiful little girl it's just there
are actual problems in this country guys
and you're not facing them down you're
not interested in them you're too busy
calling Trump a racist for a speech that
is not racist you're too busy suggesting
that American history is a horror show
and that July 4th is all about the
repression of black people and doing
what have you what did you do today to
stop the cheating seriously what did you
do today I want to hear about it I hear
black lives matter from the black lives
matter protestors what did you do today
to stop that shooting because on a
statistical level the people you ought
to be worried about are the people who
are murdered every day in places like
Chicago that doesn't mean you have to
ignore police brutality police brutality
should never be ignored it doesn't mean
that we should ignore a racial shooting
if you find one they're extremely rare
if you can find one by the cops it
doesn't mean we should ignore one bad
thing to focus on another thing it
doesn't mean a lack of proportionality
in terms of our attention does suggest
something about your underlying view of
the United States okay over the weekend
an eight-year-old child was murdered
near that Wendy's in Atlanta remember
how much time have we spent in this
country talking about Rashad Brooks
Irish art Brooks is the man who attacks
two police officers stole a Taser off
one fired at an officer fired another
officer before he was shot
generated a national news story a
national news story how much attention
do you think is gonna be paid to an
eight-year-old child who's murdered near
Wendy's in Atlanta yesterday and by the
way you want to talk about a horrifying
story apparently this happened right
near the Wendy's what exactly happened
well the police identified the girl as
Sakura aterna she was shot as she and
her mom tried parking in a liquor store
lot near an armed civilians barricade
around the Wendy's where Rashard Brooks
was killed so the car was stopped by
criminals who then shot into the car and
murdered a child and murdered a child
when the driver attempted to enter a
liquor store parking lot on the 1200
block of Pryor Road police say he was
confronted by a group of armed
individuals who had blocked the entrance
by the way the Democrats are considering
the mayor of Atlanta as a possible VP
candidate for Joe Biden protesters had
recently erected illegal barricades
according to authorities encircling the
nearby Wendy's where Rashad Brooks was
shot and killed by an Atlanta police
officer last month at some point during
the confrontation according to the mayor
she said at least two men fired multiple
times of the vehicle killing an
eight-year-old girl well done well but
but it's the cut the cops are the
problem clearly we need fewer cops in
the land
I would solve the problem the parents of
this little girl we're on we're on the
news talking about this saying you say
black lives matter and then you killed a
child like the footage is heartbreaking
it's just heartbreaking
they say you killed your own get your
own it I'm dead because of burial they
killed my baby because she crossed the
barrier and mad at you telling you
killed a child she knew not to nobody
they said sure not my call before we can
even make a u-turn show my tires out
like Wang okay this is not we should we
should never we should never ignore
problems that are happening when it
comes to again police brutality or
racism or anything like that nobody
wants to including police officers I
know many of them none of them want root
allottee and racism in their ranks there
are a few of them who are bad people
just like in every profession it has
hundreds of thousands of employees
they're bad people but the amount of
attention that we in the United States
are paying to the evils of police
officers when the solution to problems
like the one you're having in Chicago or
Atlanta is more police not fewer it
demonstrates an underlying view of the
country that is simply untenable and
wrong alright well we'll be back here
tomorrow with more content go check us
out at daily wire calm you can pre-order
a copy of my new book how to destroy
America in three easy steps
over though their otherwise we will see
you later I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director Pavel why douse key technical
producer austin stevens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam
SIA vets audio is mixed by micro Romina
hair and makeup is by Nika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Kleber show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]